jim trotter from the nfl network was on
the ground out there in canton ohio did
you get a little misty seeing charles
woodson sing to his mom up there on that
stage jim
i i don't know that i got misty but you
get goosebumps
um it's always the hall of fame weekend
is always my
for me the most special weekend on the
nfl calendar
because it's the most exclusive club in
professional sports
and when you see these greats around
each other
and you see them sort of let down their
guard that oftentimes they may have up
with the media during the course of
their career
it's just it's i can't begin to put it
into words for you all
um and as a voter it
you know i never really understood the
impact that this honor has on these men
until after chris carter got elected in
and i tell this story that that
following fall
i was sent down to work on a feature on
uh giovanni bernard and he was
friends with chris's family growing up
and whatnot and so we went down to
interview chris at his home in florida
and during a break in the shooting he
takes him back into his
his office and on the desk in his office
as a photo album
from that weekend during the hall of
fame ceremonies when he was inducted
and as he talked about it you know his
eyes started to well up and tears
started to fall
and you just realize what that honor
means to them no matter what the
these men have accomplished on the field
and and that sort of thing
um this is something that's really
important to them and means a lot
and um again as part of it means that
they are part of the greatest club or
most exclusive club
in professional sports jim trotter joins
the show nfl network
of course the host of the huddle and
flow podcast we all got to see
the comforts of our own home these
speeches on stage but being on the
ground
in canton ohio for the weekend's
festivities i would imagine you got to
see
some things behind the scenes any
encounters in the hotel lobby
or off stage that our audience you think
would
would appreciate no you know they keep
these guys on a fairly tight schedule
um during hall of fame week and there's
so many things for them to do
and actually it's almost like these guys
need a vacation when it's over
um because it's actually kind of a grind
it's a pleasant grind but it's grind
uh where there are so many functions and
different things that they have to
attend
so um now that you know the best part
for me is kind of after these guys get
inducted in when they come back and now
they can really just kind of
kick back and enjoy the weekend and you
may see them on a golf course
you may see them you know out at dinner
or something like that or at one of the
parties
that the inductees are throwing and you
can just have honest conversations about
things that maybe they wouldn't open up
about when they were playing
and um so i enjoy those moments and
you know it's funny i live out here in
san diego and one of the guys who lives
out here is damani dawson the steelers
hall of fame center
and we both like to golf so we'll try
and get together a couple times a month
and just to be able to spend time with
these guys and
and and to see that human part of them
where you know you take the helmet off
and
and you learn what they're really about
i wish everyone could do that
well it's incredible to see them like
you said have those human moments
be shared on a big stage like that but
it's also incredible to see
the appreciation for family
and you hear how kurt warner was
thinking of you know
giving it all up because it was too much
of a toll on his family
walk us through sort of just the
importance of family to these guys you
spend so much time with hall of famers
you're a hall of fame voter when you
hear peyton get up there start crying
mentioning his dad
just the family that goes into
supporting the the football dreams of
all these players
yeah the thing is these guys don't make
it alone and so when you heard jimmy
johnson say
that he never had an opportunity to see
his sons
play youth football and i shouldn't say
never had an opportunity but never
took the opportunity to see them play
youth football because he said he wanted
to out work everyone
and to realize later what that meant to
him and what he had missed out on
you know to hear um troy palamalo talk
about being the best
best man that he could uh for his wife
setting that example for his kids to see
what
you know how a man should treat a woman
and his wife
those sorts of things um it's incredible
one of the other things that that for me
resonated was when you heard bill cower
talking about marty schottenheimer and
he talked about
pat shottenheimer marty's wife how she
took him
and his family under her wing one thing
about the schonheimer family and
having covered them is that they truly
viewed football
and the teams that they were on as
family
and i joke with pat that she was sort of
the mother hen
you know she oversaw everyone so um
these families sacrifice a lot for these
these players to be where they are and
that's why
for instance when drew brees retired i
tweeted out and said you know
a person we should be giving the flowers
to uh
as well as drew is his wife knowing drew
the way that i do having covered him
since he came into the league
you know britney allowed him
to be the most dedicated player that he
could be and if you know drew brees
he put everything he had into being a
great player in terms of his time his
energy
his commitment and when the family has
young kids
um somebody has to be there to be that
rock on a day-to-day basis
while the husband is out doing what he's
doing and so to me
brittany breese was so important to what
br drew was able to accomplish
and it's not just just brittany you can
go down the line with all of these
families in terms of what the wives
and the kids have given up to allow
their husband or their father to be
successful at a really high level
so i thought it was great to um to hear
these men
pay homage to to their families you know
you heard john lynch do it with his wife
and i think it's tremendous you know
because i don't think they get enough
credit for what they sacrifice in terms
of allowing these men
to become the players that they become
jim trotter from the nfl network huddle
and flow podcast joins the show ben
lyons in for rich on the rich eisen
show let's stick with the family of the
new orleans saints
if you're the saints and you wake up to
some cryptic tweets from michael thomas
on a monday morning
how do you react i think what the first
thing you do is you don't
overreact look
there is a lot of speculation about
what's going on with michael thomas and
whatnot all i can tell you is that when
i was down at [ __ ] camp
you know i talked to sean payton about
it sean loves
michael thomas he knows that he's a
sensitive individual
he can be an emotional individual but
sean
feels he has a special relationship with
michael thomas so
while we on the outside may overreact to
things
uh sean is not one of those people
that's going to overreact to
to any of that so i can't tell you what
michael meant by that
only he can um i do know this
when you talk to folks uh he's
tremendously hard working
he cares about his teammates but he's
gone through some things
and you know i'm not going to get into
all of them here
but um i think what he said is true we
don't have both sides of the story
we only know what was put out there and
i always come back to this too to be
honest with you
you know when we say we don't have both
sides of the story it's not that we as
journalists don't attempt to get both
sides of the story
it may be that the player at that time
is not ready to give his side of the
story
and oftentimes that happens and that's
why the hall of fame is so great because
sometimes stories that that
they wouldn't address during their
careers they will speak about when it's
all over
so i don't know specifically what's
happening or what michael met
behind that tweet i just know until we
hear from him i don't think anyone
should overreact
another camp i know you've been covering
this year is out in cleveland the
cleveland browns
have expectations is it super bowl or
bust for the browns that sounds like a
wild thing to say
yeah no one out there framed it that way
to me that it's super bowl or buzz but
clearly expectations are high there
and this is a team that um
[Music]
you know had success at the end of the
year but what kevin stefanski told me
one of the things he said to his team
coming into camp is look we have a lot
of work to do let's not forget
we finished in third place in our
division you know so we've got two clubs
in our own division that are ahead of us
so there's work to do and then you look
at the fact that defensively
they could have potentially nine new
starters how quickly will it take for
all of these players to assimilate
and to gel and to become the unit that
they want to become
what i do know a positive sign the first
day of training camp when they put on
pads
um you're talking about a defense with
so many new faces matching up against an
offense that returns virtually everyone
and the defense wreaked havoc that day
so that is a positive for the browns
going forward
it doesn't mean anything but yet at the
same time it does mean something
in terms of what the potential of this
unit can be andrew barry their gm
did a tremendous job in terms of going
out and getting the type of players
that they feel they need to be
successful defensively they knew in year
one of the barry stefanski
tandem that they wanted to try and
address the offense
to put parts around baker mayfield for
him to be successful
and it was kind of implicitly understood
that it was going to take at least a
year to get the parts that they need
defensively
but they've gone out this year and
they've done that so this is a team to
me that's going to be fun to watch this
year
jim trotter joins the show nfl network
ben lyons in for rich
on the rich eisen show you can check out
jim's podcast
huddle and flow i want to ask you about
this lamar jackson situation
in baltimore because uh the news coming
out that he's now
been diagnosed with coven 19 for a
second time yet remains
unvaccinated what are your thoughts as
someone who's covered the league for so
long
the story of vaccinated and unvaccinated
players heading into this
nfl season you know i've tried not to to
overreact to all of this i can only
speak from a personal standpoint i wish
everyone would get vaccinated
um when you start to see the numbers
trend upward again
and not even trend in some cases spike
upward again
um it's concerning and you know i really
have questions about whether or not
we're going to have an entire season of
open stadiums
because when you see large gatherings
and then the data shows that after many
of these large gatherings
the covet numbers spike in those areas
it makes me concerned that we may not
have open stadiums for a full season and
if there's one thing
for me personally um it's just not the
nfl without the fans
in the stadium and so safety comes first
and i'm hoping
that everyone will vaccinate and that we
can get through a season where we have
open stadiums but
i don't know what lamar's reasons are
for being unvaccinated
um you know obviously we've heard all
the different reasons that people have
given out there
but for me you know i don't want to go
too far and say that it's selfish but in
some
there are occasions where i feel like
it's that way because it's not about
just you it's about those who you could
infect and what impact it could have on
them so
um again personally speaking i would
hope that lamar and
and all the players would get vaccinated
but
you know to each his own jim we
appreciate you taking some time i know
you're down in san diego so uh 12 noon
tee time is in the cards today or are
you going with twilight rate
uh there's no golf today man there's
work to do well we appreciate you for uh
for making some time from the work day
uh to spend it with us and hope you do
get back on the golf course soon
i appreciate you man thanks for having
me jim trotter from the nfl network
huddle and flow podcast he was out there
in canton ohio
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here